most likely to Peyton versus Eli CH go
Corona the fastest I would win that for
sure be the head coach of an NFL team
that would be Peyton beat Tom Brady in
the playoffs well we've both done it and
he's beaten him in the playoffs I've
beaten him in the Super Bowl so Super
Bowl that's point that counts win in a
foot race that would be me by a lot
Peyton's the slowest by a lot has he
always been the slowest since he was 10
years old been slow win a game of Madden
I think I would win at a game of Madden
as well I've played more video games
than he has get us beating to get a
speeding ticket he's a terrible driver
he follows people very closely and stops
at the last minute always in a rush win
in a dance off oh I don't think anyone
wants to see that that's just like a
lose lose situation for everybody
watching have a better golf swing
unfortunately he's got a little better
golf swing than me and I'm it upsets me